we know of a person a young boy
that by the time he was six years old he
was shot twice
on two different occasions
uh one time he was shot at the
playground and another time he was shot
in the confines of his own home
[Music]
what's up everybody my name is cooper
brooks and i'm coming to you from the
rooftop that's right on the south side
of chicago on where they call obi wan we
call me too but oh for opportunity
i want to thank you for tuning in to our
rooftop revelations i'm staying right
here in this tent for 100 days from
november 20th to february 28th bringing
attention and awareness of the violence
in chicago but also trying to build a
community center that is so desperately
needed
so every now and then here at the
rooftop revelations i get an opportunity
to bring to you
friends who are helping us and assisting
us
to do all the things that we're trying
to do to transform this community the
day i have a meeting none other than
pastor tj crumbs my right hand man my
assistant who helps me on a consistent
basis especially when it comes to the
issues of dealing with our young black
men
that's tj thanks for being with us on
rooftop revelations
i want to jump right in i want people to
understand how difficult it is
um
ministering serving assisting mentoring
uh
young brothers in this neighborhood
the
work the struggle that it is
uh well for one um
what better way to give an example
we know of a person a young boy
that by the time he was six years old he
was shot twice
on two different occasions
uh one time he was shot at the
playground and another time he was shot
in the confines of his own home
and so a young boy that's six years old
can you imagine the trauma can you
imagine the stress can you imagine what
he has to go through on a daily basis
and uh you know as a pastor as a
minister as a servant
you look back and you say how in the
world can i serve a young boy like this
who has been traumatized like this what
can i do
and and and something that uh i really
believe wholeheartedly is not only do we
give him the gospel but but
it is important and imperative that we
present him another path
that would help him choose something
yeah and so um i'm a believer that uh
it is our job to raise his level of
expectation and you can't raise his
level of expectation without raising his
level of exposure and so i think that's
imperative and important that we show
him at the age of 69 now uh and and we
expose him to different counseling and
we expose him to different people that's
going to help him examine and see how he
grew up in a different way in a
different light instead of using it as
something that's going to make him uh
angry and frustrated he can use it as a
tool to help other people that's going
through some of the same things that he
went through right i remember when we
were
we had the kids for summer in summer
camp and
one of the teachers in our summer camp
wanted to get rid of him wanted to send
him home
and it was because they did not
understand the trauma that he
experienced and i can remember having to
sit down and explain to her listen this
little boy
has gone through a lot of trauma
and if we kick him out
where else is he going to go exactly and
that's reason why
for me
the community center is so important yes
because there's so many kids just like
him they may not have been shot but
they've definitely gone through trauma
their brothers and sisters and mothers
and fathers have gone through
shooting ordeals and
they have no place to go so for us we
got to get this center up that's right
so that we can build capacity that's
right you can have more summer programs
right more carpentry programs right
electrical programs and even give these
kids a chance to learn how to swim you
know we talk about this all the time
kids in our neighborhood don't even know
how to swim never seen a swimming pool
yeah right exactly never see this film
so man i want to thank you for the work
that you do
and
how you assist in making life better for
a lot of people
and it is you know we talk about it it's
glorious hard work and i want to thank
you for being committed to it
we're going to keep doing it to the
wheels fallout yes sir all right
thank y'all for tuning in to rooftop
revelations and
all i can say is just i'll see you
tomorrow peace
you